ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre madame la Première
ministre après le confinement sanitaire
est venu le temps du confinement
énergétique l'électricité plus 10%. le
gaz plus 34 % le fuel plus 70 % pire
encore des millions de Français ne
trouvent même plus de carburant pour
circuler après le temps de la vie chère
est venu le temps de la France en
carence carence de carburant et carence
de gouvernement car les Français sont
fatigués d'entendre que tout va bien
alors qu'ils attendent des heures pour
faire le plein les Français sont
fatigués de voir leur gouvernement
réagir trop peu ou trop tard l'effort
les Français sont fatigués de chercher
des produits qui disparaissent des
rayons les Français sont fatigués de
voir leur pays s'enfoncer chaque jour
davantage car derrière l'arbre des
carburants se cache la forêt des
pénuries cela avait commencé il y a
quelques mois avec la moutarde et
l'huile de tournesol aujourd'hui la
France n'a même plus de quoi circuler et
demain elle ne pourrait même plus avoir
de quoi se chauffer après les
raffineries ce sont nos centrales
nucléaires qui se mettent en grève
allez-vous là aussi attendre des jours
pour réagir aux grèves préventives nous
demandons des actions préventives
qu'attendez-vous pour acquisitionner
toutes les raffineries qu'attendez-vous
madame la Première ministre pour dire
comme votre Ministre de l'économie que
ce mouvement des raffineries est
illégitime et inacceptable
qu'attendez-vous pour joindre la parole
aux actes et permettre aux Français de
se déplacer et vivre libre